- Is Windbender anime?
(crew laughing)
Yeah yeah.
(slow funky music)
- It's like Japanese cartoons?
- I don't think it's all porn
but probably a lot of it is, right?
- Mystical type story lines.
- I don't know, maybe I'll love it.
- Lot of breathy action here.
- The eyeball budget is off the rails.
- That's one thing about anime
it has unrealistic eye expectations.
- [bleeped] is going down!
- Oh [bleeped] this dude is big!
- These robots are for sure
going to kill all of them.
- He's got a big butt too.
- Butts! Just endless butts!
- Oh that's a Titan!
I thought that was like Shaft
who's going to be some hero.
- They're all like "We need to run"
but they're not running!
You need to get the hell out of your town.
- Like, Spongebob
doesn't have this kind of
drama in it, you know?
- Did anyone think to
stop and ask for a second,
maybe they're nice?
- No! Gotta save you're mom!
- The mom is just like,
"The debris has crushed my legs!"
this is bleak as [bleeped].
- This is so dark. This is so dark.
- Whoa, this dude's got robot legs.
- A [bleeped] with a jet pack
comes in out of no where!
- Indiana Jones just showed up!
- Why is he blond?
- What the [bleeped] is
this creepy ass [bleeped]?
- Hi! Hello!
- Flashbacks to when he
was a kid, just tears.
- He's going to eat her face off.
- It found her?
Out of all the rubble it found her?
- Oh, come on!
- You're [bleeped] kidding right now.
- Tell me he's not
going to eat his mother.
Oh my god.
(screaming)
(gasping)
- What? Are you [bleeped] kidding me?
- He just opened her up like a cashew.
- That's it?
- Wow that was [bleeped] crazy.
I want to watch the next one though.
- I just assumed that all anime
is about a school girl trying
to avenge her father's death.
- Oh [bleeped] they're
not wearing anything.
- That is...
that can't be armor.
That is not protecting her that much.
- I don't know what's happening.
There's so many colors.
- She's wearing suspenders
over her nipples.
- Who's this onlooker?
This like Popeye looking...
- She's super naked.
- She's flirting with some
like, spirit, or something.
- I can see why people,
not me, but some people might like this.
- Oh [bleeped]. Oh [bleeped].
Some Dragonball Z [bleeped].
- She's got a giant scissor on her back.
I can only assume that's
some sort of sexual metaphor.
- This, this'll definitely cause seizures.
- Defied my expectations more than it
met what I thought anime was.
- I definitely appreciate it more
but I don't know if I would watch it.
- Anime has the option to be like
really cool kick ass girls
doing cool [bleeped] like what
I remember Sailor Moon to be
and then some people take it and ruin it
and make it like weird
sexualized cartoons.
- I thought it was going
to be way more cute,
way more animals.
- Here's what I loved, I
loved the cinematography
of the animation like
the first one especially
there was such movement, such action.
- It seems like a big investment
to get into.
- Just me and the wife cuddling
up to some smiling Titans.
- Yeah I'd totally watch Attack on Titans.
I might go watch it tonight.
(slow funky music)